hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle now do you
know what this is
well you should do it's a floppy disk an
analog of modern flash drives and sd
cards and also comes from the 90s now
one and a half megabytes of information
fit on it now it could be used to store
documents or transfer programs and even
operating systems were sold using them
for example doom 2 occupied 5 different
floppy disks and windows 3.11 occupied
as many as eight
but why am i bringing up such an
artifact now well it's quite interesting
but every second we spend on the
internet we generate data the size of
such a floppy disk photos music posts
memes video streams if you saved all of
that on floppy disks you need a stack of
70 meters high per day every day
together we generate 2.5 quintillion
bytes of information that's a lot and
today i'm going to tell you how to
protect the most important part of all
of this information
it's as expensive as gold as necessary
as oil and as explosive as gunpowder so
let's look at the main upcoming trend of
2022 privacy enhancing computing
[Music]
nearly 80 of americans are actually
concerned about how companies are using
their personal data
more than half of users often refuse to
use specific services or software due to
concerns about the confidentiality of
their personal information now ordinary
people are thinking about protecting
their personal correspondence i'm not
talking about hackers or cyber criminals
but journalists engineers and teachers
they're leaving whatsapp and creating
accounts and signal or telegrams so that
their messages aren't found in the work
screens of facebook moderators equally
to protect themselves from the
all-seeing eye of contextual advertising
ordinary users are abandoning safari and
google and instead of using brave and
duck.go
they're not using public wi-fi networks
but rather have mastered vpn and tor
technologies instead it's a real
revolution but not only users are afraid
for their personal data for many
companies working with such information
also creates a lot of problems they
simply don't have the opportunity to
create their own personal data
processing system so well they have to
turn to other companies for help
and then everything
gets bad
very bad
as an example in recent years 56 of
companies that have used the services of
third-party personal data operators have
encountered their unfair use but what do
i mean by that well in 42 of those cases
the data was simply stolen by intruders
nice opinion
one small issue
i am inside your home because that it's
not surprising that are more and more
startups in silicon valley aimed at
protecting your personal data according
to crunchbase investments in them have
already exceeded three billion dollars
those investments are growing day by day
in addition to the security of working
with data there's another problem here
information duplication
now social networks payment systems car
rental services insurance companies
government authorities i mean these will
require you to enter the same data right
your phone number your surname first
name driver's license bank cards maybe
we repeatedly enter this data in
different applications and on different
websites and we also spend a lot of time
on two-factor authentication we copy
codes from
sms's we
take qr code photos or follow temporary
links and i'm fed up with all of this
and fortunately i'm not the only one
here more and more it companies are
beginning to invest their resources into
the development of something called pec
[Music]
so pc privacy enhancing computing it's a
new approach to working with personal
information it basically addresses the
issues of confidential data processing
and also its analysis and this includes
everything that does not concern the
direct storage and copying of protected
information but what does this all mean
in practice well let's take a look
[Music]
if you often pay for online purchases
with bank cards then you probably
remember your security codes off by
heart mastercard has these codes called
cvc2
visa has cvv2 but the essence is
basically the same these are the three
numbers that are finally written on the
back of your card knowing this code
basically confirms that you're the card
holder
so the card validation code contains
only three digits but this means that
there are only 999 different codes or
maybe less
i've never seen a code that consists of
only zeros repeated digits or three
consecutive digits for example one two
three
but on the other hand i've only had
about a dozen cards in my entire life
and it would be too rash to draw any
conclusions from such a small sample
therefore in order to test the
hypothesis about the non-random
principle of the formation of codes i'm
going to ask you for your help please
write your cvv or cvc code in the
comments below this video i'm going to
collect the statistics and probability
of meeting a beautiful code or better
yet even send a photo of the back of
your card to my email address
stop stop stop of course i'm joking
security codes as well as pin codes or
passwords from banking applications
these things can never be published in
plain text anywhere okay i hope i won't
be seeing these three digit codes in the
comments but we'll see otherwise you
might be left with no money in your
account
[Music]
so is it possible to test this
hypothesis but at the same time not
disclose any confidential information
yes remember in the video about
cryptocurrencies i mentioned hash
functions these are complex mathematical
transformations that allow you to turn
your secret data into a string of
letters and numbers and moreover this
resulting string can be openly published
it's almost impossible to calculate the
original value and if you had this
string of your cvv code you could put it
in the youtube description
look i'm going to actually enter three
digits of a random cvv code into the
online hash generator
now zero four nine will turn into this
set of
characters see if i use the same
function for code 048 or 050 the results
will be completely different and if i
tell you that the hash code from my card
looks like this
the only way you'd be able to find out
my real number is by calculating all
possible variants of the hash function
for every single number between 0 and
999 good luck with that now if i were to
compare a couple of thousand hashes from
real cvv codes i can actually do a
statistic analysis on those hashes if i
find that the hashes are repeated more
often than probability theory would
allow then i actually understand the
codes are not created randomly and also
be able to count how many lucky people
have the code on their card that matches
mine of course the algorithms that are
used in real privacy-enhancing computing
systems are much more complicated but
the principle really remains the same
different systems can share data for the
joint processing of data and at the same
time they'll have to disclose them
this algorithm is called secure
multi-party computing today it's used in
areas related to the processing of
sensitive data and this is far from the
only pc algorithm do you remember in one
of the previous videos i talked about
zero knowledge proofs well this is
another way to basically implement the
principles of privacy enhancing
computing and on a side note if you're
interested in this topic let us know in
the comments because we can do some new
videos where we'll talk about three more
basic pc methods there's private set
intersection we can talk about private
information retrieval and also fully
homomorphic encryption
[Music]
in real life privacy-enhancing
communicators are already being used in
several areas at once and perhaps the
most high profile case is the boston
study on the wage gap between men and
women
now usually such studies require real
data on wages in different companies and
of course these companies are no hurry
to publish such information open data
well can become a reason for lawsuits
about say wage inequality and also it's
easier for competitors to head hunt if
they know how much employees are getting
at their current place of work moreover
the researchers didn't want to use the
services of intermediary companies that
would guarantee the confidentiality of
data just for a few reasons first of all
it would undoubtedly lead to additional
costs and secondly any additional
intermediary increases the likelihood of
say a leakage of sensitive information
now aza bestavros director of the
institute for computing and
computational science and engineering
suggested another solution to this he
developed a software that basically used
randomly selected large numbers to mask
real data from outside observers without
disclosing specific data for each of the
60 companies bestavros proved that white
women earn only 83 cents for every
dollar that men earn
what did you just say now for women of
color the statistics were even worse the
results of the study provided the
impetus for the launch of a special
programme run by the mayor of boston to
combat this injustice so as we can see
this algorithm behind protected data has
already helped tens of thousands of
people to improve their living
conditions now such privacy-enhancing
computing methods allow for complex
research that actually conventional deep
personalization algorithms do not work
for and this is especially important in
the field of evidence-based medicine
case histories of patients from all over
the world can be processed without the
risk of disclosure of personal or
sensitive data now you understand how
important this opportunity is in a world
choking with conflict information
regarding covert 19. pc also helps to
effectively solve another problem not to
identify general trends in the data but
to find anomalies and this helps to
build an effective system to counter
network fraud
[Music]
now increasingly they're being used to
identify fraudsters in the financial
insurance markets
criminals usually try to pull off scams
with several companies that are working
in the same industry at once and the
problem is here each company has to try
and figure out the scammers on their own
it takes a lot of time and effort to do
so therefore serious players are forced
to become clients of companies that
solve the problems of verifying user
documents with their own methods for
example such companies might detect
fakes in a scanned document they might
compare faces with the faces and say a
driving license and i've already tested
such systems for durability so if you're
the owner of a crypto exchange or a
yacht rental company watch that video
now these systems work pretty well but
the problem is that even if one company
in the market is able to identify
fraudster the rest well they won't know
about that fraudster and legislation
severely restricts the maintenance of
say blacklists which would include the
data of unreliable users but with the
help of privacy-enhancing computing
companies are able to safely cooperate
with each other for example they can
create a list of reliable digital
identities without exchanging the
personal data of the users it's great
and imagine for example that by
contacting a new car sharing company you
no longer have to fill out all those
endless forms and wait for the results
of document verification your
trustworthiness will effectively be
vouched for and confirmed by other
market participants and all at the same
time your personal information cannot
get linked to the black market it's
tempting isn't it
privacy enhancing computing is a whole
set of cryptographic technologies and
they basically help to solve the
problems of secure storage and use of
confidential data pc enables different
systems to work together with your
personal information without the
exchange of open data switching to such
technologies can actually help
businesses to find new customers
a huge number of people still don't
trust existing means of data protection
and actually about 27 of users never
enter their real personal data when
registering on a website or let's say on
an application if it's possible not to
do so on the other hand scandals related
to say high profile leaks of personal
data are forcing government agencies of
different states to adopt more and more
new laws on confidentiality and
information protection and it's
especially difficult for companies that
operate in several countries at once for
them the anonymity and security of
privacy-enhancing computing becomes a
real way to resist the pitfalls of local
legislation therefore i share in the
opinion of gartner experts who promised
that by 2025 60 of all large
organizations will implement pc methods
in their verification systems well we'll
know soon enough anyway i'd like to
thank you for joining me on another
privacy enhancing entropic escapade
around the evanescent enclaves of
minecraft's end i'll see you in the next
video thanks for joining us
[Music]